In the last few weeks, my face is very red, is this rosacea?
What is the reason is it connected to gut health?
Well, certainly, you could google pictures of rosacea,
and see if your redness looks like a rosacea ranch.
If you can look at those Google pictures of rosacea,
it goes, oh my gosh, that's exactly what it looks like.
Then you know that it's H. Pylora.
So, H. Pylora is the cause of rosacea.
There could be other reasons for a red face.
That isn't H. Pylora, because it isn't rosacea.
So, getting a proper diagnosis would be an order.
So, if you don't feel comfortable going to Google and looking at pictures,
then getting into a practitioner that could identify rosacea,
maybe a dermatologist would be an order.
But if it is a rosacea, then it is H. Pylora.
Is that a gut issue?
Well, yes and no.
It starts in the gut, but it doesn't necessarily stay in the gut.
Again, that's the problem with doing a test for H. Pylora.
You got three main ways to test for H. Pylora.
You could do the urea breath test.
That will be positive if you have H. Pylora elevated in the stomach.
Maybe in the first part of the first part of the guanda.
But if it's not elevated in the stomach anymore,
and it's elevated in the intestinal tract,
then a stool sample tested for H. Pylora, which are positive.
If it's not elevated in the stomach anymore,
not elevated in the intestinal tract,
then the urea breath test and the stool sample may be negative.
The other test is the anti-body test.
The test is kind of useless because that will be elevated.
That's typically just an IGG test.
I don't think they have an IG on test for H. Pylora.
I haven't seen that maybe they could know.
So that's just going to test past exposure.
It doesn't super high elevated enough to give you clues of courage exposure.
So you have to look at other factors as well.
If you had a history of H. Pylora,
then the knowledge that the fact that it could very well and very most commonly
could will go systemic and affect other parts of the body.
The skin is very common.
It's rosacea.
It's caused by H. Pylora,
but it could cause other skin rashes.
I had patients where it was a weird rash all the way down just their left arm.
There was a weird case.
I didn't know what it was.
When I looked at it, certainly looked anything like rosacea.
Didn't have it.
It was a weird record case.
Tested them and it was rosacea.
And it was that rosacea was H. Pylora.
And we treated for H. Pylora.
Literally the rash went away in a few days.
Just could boy going on.
Kytos.
Burberry and garlic.
The things that you would do for H. Pylora.
But if you have a systemic H. Pylora,
then you just have to assume that it's affected.
You're endothelial cells.
And that's the worst case scenario.
So, I mean, of course, worst case scenario would be H. Pylora causing cancer.
But H. Pylora does cause cancer.
It's a double one causes systemic cancer.
It's a common cause of prostate cancer and other cancers as well.
But it is one of the most common cause of endothelial disorder.
So, causing damage and inflammation to the lining of your arteries.
And of course, you know, we all want to get rid of cancer.
And we don't want to die of heart disease while we're waiting to try to get rid of cancer.
So, I'm from the firm belief that everybody should treat themselves as if they have H. Pylora.
I mean, at least in a pulse that the needy that I'll take are.
Para clear, which is a great H. Pylora killer, because it's got.
It's got it in the form which here right away.
That's because I take it.
It's got different parasites.
I think it's like black walnut or regular oregano is actually good for H. Pylora.
Where would.
The clove garlic is really good clove is really good for liver parasites liver foods.
Garlic powder, which is really good for all parasites.
Good for cancer. Good for your heart.
Add good for.
Tilly needs point. All right.
And it's got slippery elbow bark, which is really good to help heal your gut.
It's got a castorous and rot, which is good for your gut.
Violet golden seal, which is good for H. Pylora.
Great food seed extract, which is good for H. Pylora.
Also good for multiple other parasites.
Barberry root, which is good for H. Pylora in a source of burberry.
So I take that.
Not daily, but regularly.
Also take burberry.
Very regularly.
So one of my favorite things for H. Pylora.
I think everybody should be knowledgeable about H. Pylora.
That's why I tell people to read.
The blog post a helical actor.
Pylora and things to do to deal with it.
And follow those steps.
I think everybody needs to address that, whether you have cancer or not.
Because it is just so prevalent.
And I don't want you as a cancer patient to have a heart attack.
It's, you know, it's easy to be model minded.
Single minded on our focus of treated cancer.
And we have other co-orbidities that could.
You know, cause us health.
So we have to be reminded about that.